Russie on va aller prendre le pouls du
côté de l'Ukraine qui a vous nous
retrouvons Elena veloshin Elena bonjour
on vient d'entendre les réactions
britanniques et américaines aux propos
de Vladimir Poutine quelle réaction
acquieve après cette dernière à cette
dernière intervention
écoutez c'est exactement la même
réaction ici de la part de l'Ukraine et
des Ukrainiens c'est-à-dire que cet
appel à la mobilisation générale cette
ordre de mobilisation générale de
Vladimir Poutine et vécu ici comme un
affreux un aveu d'échec voire un aveu de
défaite il faut comprendre pour que pour
les Ukrainiens cet appel à la
mobilisation ne change pas grand chose
l'Ukraine est un pays qui ne doute à
aucun moment de sa victoire pendant même
que je vous parle je vois ici sur l'une
des rues de Kiev un panneau publicitaire
qui explique comment lancer une start-up
après la victoire donc pour les
Ukrainiens en fait le fait que après
leur contre-offensive spectaculaire
lancer le premier à septembre par le
président volody mirzelenski ou l'armée
ukrainienne est parvenue à reprendre
plusieurs milliers de kilomètres carrés
de son territoire en quelques jours à
peine et bien après le succès de cette
contre-offensive alors même que les
soldats Ukrainiens racontent là-bas au
nord-est dans la région de kerkiff que
les soldats russes sont abandonnés leur
position ont fui sans même opposé de
résistance et bien pour eux aujourd'hui
le fait que Vladimir Poutine en appelle
assez réser c'est que il est vraiment
acculé qu'il n'a pas d'autre choix et de
fait on l'a entendu dans la déclaration
du président russe il semble que il
cherche à prendre des mesures qui
viennent pallier au réellement aux
problèmes que rencontre l'armée russe
sur le terrain à savoir en premier lieu
ce ne sont pas seulement les armes mais
ce sont aussi les hommes la motivation
des hommes on a vu ces derniers jours
circuler sur les réseaux sociaux ces
vidéos très impressionnantes de celui
qui qui ressemble au chef de la
compagnie militaire primpé il y a gagné
Prigogine venir recruter dans les
prisons et selon de nombreux témoignages
qui se multiplient aussi de famille de
prisonniers hormis ses vidéos et bien il
semblerait qu'effectivement Yetu un
grand recrutement dans les dans les
prisons russes et ce parmi les pires
criminels les violeurs les assassins et
bien c'est ce sont ces gens là aux yeux
des Ukrainiens aujourd'hui qui les
combattent qui viennent les combattre en
Ukraine au sein de l'armée de Vladimir
Poutine et à visiblement et bien cela ne
marche pas alors Vladimir Poutine elle
l'a dit il faut des hommes entraînés il
faut des hommes qui savent combattre
donc comme le disait Armel il n'appelle
pas d'une part à la mobilisation
générale parce que cette mesure serait
extrêmement impopulaire mais aussi il a
besoin de gens qui savent combattre sur
le terrain alors il va tenter avec les
réservistes ou le disiez son ministre de
la Défense sergueil choïcu annoncé
d'abord une mobilisation de 300000
hommes mais il dit que la réserve
possible de mobilisation en Russie
constitue 25 millions de personnes en
tout cas pour les ukrainiens et bien
ceci ne change absolument pas la donne
comme ils étaient motivés à vaincre
Vladimir Poutine et bien ils le sont
toujours merci beaucoup notre envoyé
spécial en Ukraine vous qui avez été
aussi notre correspondante en Russie
jusqu'au jusqu'au début de cette crise
la France